Tom monsters are very tenacious people
they love molesting child's it's crazy
it's like their favorite thing I mean
when you kiss it so crazy cuz when you
consider the risk in being a child
molester speaking not enough even the
damage you're doing but the risk there's
no worse life available to a human than
being a caught child molester and yet
they still do it which from you could
only really surmise that it must be
really good I mean but from their point
of view it must be amazing for them to
risk so much is that joke offensive some
people seem to think that it is what if
victims are watching what if victims
parents are watching it's such a
sickening thing that happens to people
that I know comedians try to push the
limit and they sometimes take risks and
they don't work but I think was
something like child molestation it's
just not funny and he's too clever like
he could come up with a thousand
different things what are we really
asking when we asked whether a joke or a
tweet or an image is offensive or not
we're not asking really whether someone
was offended are we know we're asking if
what was said was morally right how
could somebody determine that how do we
know when a joke for example is morally
look I feel there is no forum that is
acceptable for this ever I know somebody
that was molested at three years old
three years old
no nightclub no no place ever deserves
to have that that person seems to think
that it's the effect of the joke that
matters because child molestation is
such a sensitive subject because the
harm caused is so gruesome and lasting
because any light-hearted mention of it
could in some way diminish the suffering
of victims or bring that pain back child
molestation as a topic should be wholly
avoided in the realm of comedy
now that's certainly a persuasive
argument comedies purpose can't be to
cause pain to innocent victims but of
course that wasn't the purpose of Louis
CK's joke in the first place it wasn't
his intent it just comes down to one
question intent it's all about intent
it's only about intent in that clip
Ricky Gervais argues the opposite of
effect being the moral judge of a joke
and instead says that it's the
comedian's intention that really matters
in the end
and clearly Louis CK's intention in that
joke is to use comedy to get us to think
about society's attitude and treatment
of pedophilia perhaps see intimates that
we revile this demographic to blindly
taking solace and our normalcy when we
know that the complexities of sexuality
means that the urge to pedophilia is not
something chosen never does he forgive
or validate the act he takes it for
granted that child abuse of any kind
deserves the harshest scorn and
retribution this I think is the intent
and for many the effect of this joke a
subtle indictment of our smug
righteousness and our fear of the
lawlessness of sexuality in civilized
society indeed jokes are uniquely
designed to deliver messages like this
they sneak into consciousness past the
barriers that normally defend against
ways of thinking that threaten our
comfort now that's not to say that I
totally agree with Gervase that
intention is all that matters
clearly it isn't we have to be aware of
both the intention and the unintended
consequences of what we say we all know
that too often those in privilege define
the boundaries of morality without
taking into account the
sided ly different experiences of those
who've been subjugated or marginalized
or worse these debates about political
correctness and comedy have been
happening more and more frequently as
the Internet has given voice to more and
more people I'm always amazed at how the
arguments devolve so quickly into two
opposing camps one side will raise a
concern about a joke and the other will
come down hard defending jokes at all
costs lamenting the neverending
encroachment of PC police and social
justice warriors on free speech they
just want to use these words that's
racist that's sexist that's prejudice
they don't talking about what all this
says to me is that morality is messy it
shifts and changes now people often say
that something went over the line but
there are no lines in morality there's a
no-man's land a nebulous fringe of very
very tough questions the way I see it
great comedians are like detectives take
a look at Luther or any other detective
movie or TV show and it's easy to see
that as a society were sympathetic to
the idea of letting detectives bend the
rules for the greater good this is
because we understand that justice like
morality is abstract
detectives are trained to navigate the
swamps at the edges of justice and we
give them the leeway to do so my opinion
is that our best comedians should be
given the same reasonable leeway with
morality I don't know how the culture
determines who's allowed to do this
there are no easy answers for that I
think when a comedian is inducted into
the professions highest ranks we just
sort of know though I see how
unsatisfying an answer that is other
than that all we can do is look at the
jokes they're intense their effect and
whether or not we're laughing but if we
want our collective morality to remain
nuanced and progressive we have to let
comedians near the things we find
uncomfortable or perhaps even wrong hey
everybody
thank you so much for watching um I
wanted to let you know that I am
producing the nerve writer full timely
so I'm devoting all my time and effort
into making the best possible stuff for
you stuff that I think is I hope a cut
above the torrent of content that is
being pushed out on the internet every
day so if you think that the nerd writer
is something that you're not seeing
anywhere else on line on YouTube I want
to ask you to please support the channel
by clicking here here and pledging to my
patreon page as little as a dollar
everything helps I should let you know
that the nerd writer is always going to
be free so if you can't afford it I
don't want you to pledge but if you have
a little bit left to spare would be much
appreciated so thank you so much and
here are some more videos
you